♪ ♪
>> Judge Jeanine: JUNETEENTH
RALLIES HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS RACIAL TURMOIL
APPEARS TO BE INFLUENCING
JOE BIDEN’S SEARCH FOR RUNNING
MATE.
AMY KLOBUCHAR SAYS SHE IS BOWING
OUT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I TRULY BELIEVE, AS I
ACTUALLY TOLD THE VICE PRESIDENT
LAST NIGHT, WHEN I CALLED HIM,
THAT I THINK THIS IS A MOMENT TO
PUT A WOMAN OF COLOR ON THAT
TICKET.
IF YOU WANT TO HEAL THIS NATION
RIGHT NOW, MY PARTY, YES, BUT
OUR NATION, THIS IS SURE A HELL
OF A WAY TO DO IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: WITH
AMY KLOBUCHAR OUT, KAMALA HARRIS
ODDS ARE RISING.
A NEW POLL SHOWS DEMOCRATS FAVOR
HARRIS BY A WIDE MARGIN BUT WILL
THE RADICAL LEFT EXCEPT HER PAST
AS A PROSECUTOR?
HARRIS TRYING TO SPIN HER RESUME
AS A POSITIVE.
>> I KNOW THE SYSTEM FROM THE
INSIDE OUT.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE WE ARE GOING
TO CHANGE THE SYSTEMS THERE HAS
TO BE THE KIND OF BRILLIANT
ACTIVISM THAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM
THE OUTSIDE LIKE BLACK LIVES
MATTER AND THE LEADERSHIP THERE
COMBINED WITH WHAT WE NEED TO DO
ON THE INSIDE TO ACTUALLY APPEND
THE SYSTEMS IN A WAY THAT WE MAY
CHANGE TO GET CLOSER TO THE IDEA
UNDER THE LAW.
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL RIGHT,
JESSE, I’M GOING TO START WITH
YOU.
AMY KLOBUCHAR, I DON’T KNOW IF
SHE HAS SOMETHING IN HER THROAT
OR IF SHE WAS CHOKING BACK TEARS
BUT SHE’S ALWAYS BEEN EXTREMELY
AMBITIOUS, HAS WANTED TO BE
PRESIDENT AND CERTAINLY
VICE PRESIDENT.
WHEN SHE SAYS SHE IS BOWING OUT
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
PICK A VP BIDEN IF HE’S
PRESIDENT SHOULD PICK A VP OF
COLOR.
IS THAT THE REASON SHE’S BOWING
OUT?
A VULNERABILITY?
>> Jesse: IT’S ME SAYING I’M
WITHDRAWING MY NAME FOR
CONSIDERATION TO BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S VP PICK RIGHT
NOW.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
I THINK KAMALA IS THE TOP
CHOICE.
SHE HAS SOME NEGATIVES.
SHE IS A CHEAP SHOT ARTIST.
SHE DOESN’T REALLY HAVE POLICY
JOBS DOMESTIC OR FOREIGN.
TERRIBLE MANAGER OF HER CAMPAIGN
TOTALLY DYSFUNCTIONAL DOESN’T
HAVE THE EGGS EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY NEEDED.
BIDEN IS RUNNING AS THIS ONE
TERM HOLDOVER SO I DON’T KNOW IF
SHE TOTALLY TRUSTWORTHY.
SHE MIGHT TRY TO STAB THEM IN
THE BACK.
I’M NOT SURE SHE’S GOING TO CUT
IT.
SHE ALSO HAS A LOT OF POSITIVES.
RAISE A LOT OF MONEY.
I LIKE HER LITIGATOR STYLE.
IT’S TENACIOUS WHEN SHE GETS
THESE WITNESSES IN THEIR
CROSSHAIRS.
SHE REALLY RIPS THEIR THROAT
RIGHT OUT.
I’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT
AND THAT’S MAYBE WHAT YOU WANT
AS AN ATTACK DOG ON THE VP
TICKET.
SHE’S GOT A GREAT BACKGROUND THE
PEOPLE DO LIKE.
HER FATHER, INDIAN.
HER MOTHER, I THINK IT WAS
JAMAICAN.
IMMIGRANTS.
SHE MARRIED A JEWISH MAN.
PEOPLE LOVE THAT TYPE OF MELTING
POT STORY.
SHE LOOKS VERY ATTRACTIVE ON
TELEVISION.
AND YOU KNOW MY THING, DANA.
THE BUMPER STICKER.
BIDEN-HARRIS.
IT FITS.
IT WORKS.
NICE AND SHORT.
>> Judge Jeanine: GREG, I’M
GOING TO GO TO YOU.
YOU’VE GOT HER SAYING,
KAMALA HARRIS, BECAUSE I’VE GOT
A PROSECUTOR, I KNOW THE SYSTEM
INSIDE OUT AND I CAN CHANGE IT.
I’M NOT JUST A PROSECUTOR, AND
TAKE IT FOR ME, WE PUT PEOPLE IN
JAIL.
THAT’S KIND OF WHAT WE DO.
WE CONVICT THEM BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT BUT SHE SAYS
I’M A PROGRESSIVE PROSECUTOR.
WHAT IS OF PROGRESSIVE
PROSECUTOR?
>> Greg: WELL, FIRST I WANT TO
ADDRESS WHERE JESSE SAID THAT
KAMALA DOESN’T -- MIGHT STAB JOE
IN THE BACK.
SHE DOESN’T HAVE TO STAB JOE IN
THE BACK.
ALL SHE HAS TO DO IS SCARE HIM.
I DON’T KNOW WHY WE ARE ALL
JUMPING TO KAMALA HARRIS BECAUSE
AMY KLOBUCHAR SAID A WOMAN OF
COLOR, ALL RIGHT?
AND YOU ARE ALL OVERLOOKING LIZ
WARREN WHICH MAKES NO SENSE TO
ME.
I THINK WHAT AMY DID, WHEN AMY
DID WAS REALLY SMART.
SHE SAW THE RIDING ON THE WALL.
SHE KNEW THAT THE DECISION WAS
ALREADY MADE SO SHE WANTED TO
ACT LIKE IT WAS HER OWN IDEA.
SOMEBODY SAID I HEARD BIDEN IS
GOING TO PICK KAMALA HARRIS AND
THEN SHE GOES YOU KNOW WHAT, SHE
HAS A PRESS CONFERENCE AND SAYS
WE SHOULD -- HE SHOULD CHOOSE A
WOMAN OF COLOR.
IT’S LIKE WHEN YOU FIND OUT WHEN
YOU’RE ABOUT TO BE FIRED AND
RIGHT BEFORE THEY SAY YOU’RE
FIRED YOU SAY NO, I QUIT.
YOU DON’T GET THE SEVERANCE BUT
AT LEAST YOUR PRIDE IS INTACT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT JOE IS JUST A
SEAT FILLER FOR THE ACADEMY LIKE
THE SEAT FILLER FOR THIS JOB.
HOWEVER IS GETTING PICKED IS
GOING TO BE THE PRESIDENT IF HE
WINS.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW
DANA, KLOBUCHAR, PUT HER AWAY
FROM NOW.
KLOBUCHAR WAS A PROSECUTOR WHO
REFUSED TO PROSECUTE POLICE
BRUTALITY IN MINNEAPOLIS,
INCLUDING THE PARTICULAR
OFFICER, CHAUVIN.
SHE HAS GOT A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY WITH
VAL DEMINGS FOR EXAMPLE, THERE
YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO HAS MADE A
NAME FOR HERSELF SOMEWHAT IN THE
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
BUT SHE WAS A POLICE CHIEF, AND
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT WILL RUB
BLACK LIVES MATTER?
>> Dana: EIGHT INTERESTING
THAT YOU WENT TO THAT BECAUSE
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT I WAS
THINKING BECAUSE JESSE AND GREG
STOLE MY TWO JOKES OR ACTUALLY I
WAS GOING TO STEAL THEIRS.
I GUESS I CAN’T BE IN THE
RUNNING TO BE QUARTERBACK FOR
THE BRONCOS BECAUSE I WAS NEVER
IN THE RUNNING TO BE THE
QUARTERBACK THE BRONCOS.
PART OF THE THING THAT HAPPENED
WITH KLOBUCHAR, BECAUSE OF THE
FOCUS ON MINNEAPOLIS AND GEORGE
FLOYD AND HER REIGN THEY ARE UP
IN MINNESOTA, SHE WAS NOT GOING
TO BE THE VICE PRESIDENTIAL
CHOICE.
I AGREE SHE DEFINITELY SAW
COMING SO SHE SAID I’M GOING TO
STEP GRACIOUSLY OUT OF THE WAY.
DO YOUR POINT, VAL DEMINGS IS A
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM ORLANDO AREA
OF FLORIDA.
SHE WAS A POLICE OFFICER,
LAW ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND.
SHE WAS A POLICE CHIEF.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
TODAY AS EVENTS NEW YORK STATE
BASED BLACK LIVES MATTER
SPOKESPERSON SAY SHE IS NOT
GOING TO BE SOMEBODY THAT WE
WOULD EVER SUPPORT BECAUSE SHE
DID NOT DO ENOUGH TO DEAL WITH
POLICE BRUTALITY WHEN SHE WAS A
POLICE OFFICER.
I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO THE
VICE PRESIDENTIAL CHOICE, BUT
NEVER ONE THING FOR ANY
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE CHOOSING
A VICE PRESIDENT IS "DO NO
HARM."
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
VAL DEMINGS WHO MOST OF THE
COUNTRY DOESN’T KNOW, YOU HAVE
TO -- IT WOULD TAKE A LOT OF
EFFORT TO INTRODUCE HER TO THE
NATION, SOMEBODY LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS ALREADY HAS THAT
NAME IDEA SO THEY COULD HELP
YOU.
AND YOU ALSO HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
ONE OF TWO THINGS.
DOES HE NEED SOMEBODY THAT HE
WANTS TO WORK WITH AS A PARTNER
IF HE WERE TO BECOME PRESIDENT?
OR DOES HE NEED SOMEONE THAT
WILL HELP SHORE UP THE LEFT WING
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND DOES
HE THINK THAT PERSON CAN DO
THAT?
I THINK NO MATTER WHO IT IS AND
WHEN YOU SEE, WHATEVER THAT
PERSON’S ATTRIBUTES ARE, THAT
WILL BE WHAT HE’S MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
>> Judge Jeanine: JUAN,
KAMALA HARRIS AND THE POLICE
OFFICER, VAL DEMINGS.
BOTH OF THOSE TWO HAVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUNDS.
KLOBUCHAR DID AS WELL.
ELIZABETH WARREN IN TERMS OF
WHAT DANA WAS SAYING, "DO NO
HARM," SHE DOESN’T HAVE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND.
PEOPLE KNOW WHO SHE IS.
SHE IS VERY MUCH A PROGRESSIVE.
SHE IS VERY AGGRESSIVE.
>> Dana: SHE WOULD BE ALL HARM
HARM.
>> Judge Jeanine: IS THAT WHAT
YOU THINK, JUAN?
>> Juan: I THOUGHT DANA SAID
SOMETHING.
DANA, DO YOU WANT TO FINISH YOUR
THOUGHT?
>> Dana: I THINK
ELIZABETH WARREN, THERE IS NO
UPSIDE FOR JOE BIDEN.
WHEN I SAY DO NO HARM, SHE IS
THE OPPOSITE OF THAT.
SHE IS ALL HARM TO HIM IF HE
WERE TO PICK HER.
>> Judge Jeanine: BUT THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT WOMEN ARE HARM
AS WELL BECAUSE THEY CANNOT GET
AWAY FROM THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT
BACKGROUND.
EACH ONE OF THOSE, KAMALA HARRIS
SPENT DECADES PROSECUTING.
GO AHEAD, JUAN.
>> Juan: OKAY, SO I DISAGREE
WITH YOU.
IN FACT, I WOULD SAY FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THE SUBURBS THE
IDEA THAT YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND IS
NOT A NEGATIVE.
I THINK THERE IS AN INTENSE
FOCUS AMONG US HERE ON
"THE FIVE" ON KIND OF THE FAR
LEFT AT THIS MOMENT IN TERMS OF
THINKING ABOUT THE NEGATIVES
THAT, ESPECIALLY IN THE
AFTERMATH OF GEORGE FLOYD’S
DEATH FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
RECORDS.
I THINK IT DID HURT KLOBUCHAR.
IN CASE OF VAL DEMINGS, I THINK
THE BIG PROBLEM IS LACK OF
NATIONAL NAME RECOGNITION.
SO IT LEAVES IN MY MIND HARRIS
AND ELIZABETH WARREN.
SOME PEOPLE STILL TALKING ABOUT
STACEY ABRAMS, THE FORMER STATE
REP FROM GEORGIA WAS VERY
POWERFUL VOICE, VERY SMART
WOMAN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, YOU THINK
OF TERMS OF BLACK VOTERS AND
WANTING TO MAKE SURE BLACK VOTER
TURNOUT IS STRONG IN NOVEMBER
FOR BIDEN, IT’S SURPRISING THAT
WARREN CONSISTENTLY POLLS WELL
WITH BLACK VOTERS.
HARRIS I THINK ALSO HAS THESE
ISSUES BUT GUESS WHAT, SHE TOO
IS POPULAR.
SO TIM NEEDS BETWEEN THE TWO OF
THEM.
I THINK VAL DEMINGS IS AN
AFTERTHOUGHT AT THIS POINT.
I WOULD POINT OUT WARREN, I
THINK SHE HAD BIDEN RAISED
$6 MILLION IN ONE VIDEO
FUND-RAISER THIS WEEK.